this really amplifies our brain but I
have to put it down and I don't have it
handy I can't use it yeah but Ray I'm
not giving you a scalpel to go into my
brain and put electrodes if I have just
as good access to the cloud by holding a
smartphone and touching it with my
thumbs but you don't have to actually go
in with a scalpel I mean we'll send uh
Nanobots through the bloodstream oh I
feel much better about that now
20 years ago when people thought that
was crazy
and now everybody has this everybody's
got it I just gave a speech and 500
people there and I said who does not
have a smartphone handy and nobody
raised their hand like everybody has
this it's much better to actually have
it in your brain you have it instantly
so you'd be carrying Wi-Fi antennas
inside your head somehow right uh I mean
we'll make that more reliable than it is
now okay